[Music]
here at the winter olympics china has
debuted its digital u.n to foreign
visitors and athletes
cryptocurrencies are banned in china but
it's still a strong supporter of
blockchain tech the ecny is a
centralized cash-like digital currency
that will mostly be used for retail
payments everywhere at restaurants
stores and even on the train
so here's how it works there's this ecny
mobile app you use to set up a digital
wallet from china's central bank pboc
then you transfer money into it from
your bank account or cash at the bank
now it's time to shop
i'm gonna get some snacks
[Music]
thank you can i pick digital yen
it worked
yay
[Music]
great
my colleague alan who's also here
covering the olympics tried it out in
the cafeteria about to pay for my weird
looking spaghetti using the the digital
yen
okay choose a remedy
in april of 2020 china became the
world's first major economy to pilot a
digital currency as more people adopt
the digital un the government will have
greater control over financial
transactions it can observe how money is
spent in real time since digital
currency can be traced and recorded
accurately which also raises some
privacy concerns but for now most users
don't seem too worried
[Music]
overall it's pretty easy to use so we'll
see if other countries follow will the
u.s create a digital dollar
we'll see
[Music]